I started a meeting yesterday
introducing myself saying that I peed my
bed until I was 12. I think
self-confidence comes out of finding a
way to love yourself for what you're
good at and accepting yourself for what
you're bad at and I think most people
are so scared of the things they're bad
at that they become the skeletons in her
closet it leads to imposter syndrome you
fear what you're not good at and for me
if I can get everyone here to be more
vulnerable out loud and talk more about
what they're bad at you know I started a
meeting yesterday introducing myself
saying that I peed my bed until I was
12. you know that's not for kicks and
Giggles that's just to show people like
it's okay to own weird like that
every one of us has shortcomings that's
good everybody else sucks too and so
self-confidence comes with your
relationship on the things that you're
not confident about not the reverse and
getting used to losing like pushing
people here to do things out of their
comfort zone that are guaranteed for
them to lose is the quickest way for
them to actually be happier